[Music]
[Music]
staying on
hey miss Potts if you find this
recording don't feel bad about this part
of their journey use the end
just for the record being adrift in
space with zero promise of rescue is
more fun that sounds food water went out
four days ago
officers will run out tomorrow morning
I've been when I drift off I will dream
about him it's always you
[Music]
[Music]
danos did exactly what he said he was
gonna do
he wiped out 50% of all living creatures
we lost all of us
the best friends to us family
we lost a part of ourselves
this is the fight of our lives this is
gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't
huh is anyone home this is Scott Lang we
met a few years ago at the airport in
Germany I got really big it's just an
old message I know you know that's
that's me can you buzz me in
everything the light touches
is all kingdom
but Aki's time is ruler
rises and falls like the Sun
one day
the Sun was set on my time here
and will rise with you as the new king
[Music]
remember always remember the universe
has a way of leading into where you're
supposed to be at the moment you're
supposed to be there let's do this
it took me 20 years to find you how many
people can say that
you are the best-kept secret in the
universe and I found you
which makes be perfect for this job you
really think a black suit it's going to
solve all your problems
no but it's damn good on you we are
[Music]
recognizable only as deja vu and
dismissed just as quickly time to prove
yourself agent M we may have a problem
in London
welcome to MIB you will be with Asian
Paints
one of the best ever to ever suit
catching up on my daily meditation time
for lunch I thank you hungry
it's 9:30 Tuesdays taco day we've been
compromised with every citizen of this
planet at risk
[Applause]
you could all just to drive here just
try
gonna be fun left fun with it
there should be a big red button around
here somewhere found it we are the men
in black
looks like tables of time okay okay yeah
thanks mom a lamb is only as good as its
leaders somebody help me hey leave him
alone
a true king is brave and noble don't be
a hero on the King around here you have
more battles yet to fight
now you must choose what you stand for
Varis Dorsey was found written in the
guard put it into google translate
it means sort of partner what if you're
the only person who could have pulled
that sort out what if it's Excalibur ah
[Music]
finally follow me
I am Merlin thought one was supposed to
be analyzed and ingenious disguise do
you think in four days the dark sorcerer
Morgana will take over the world just
ridiculous
there's your sore back and good luck
with everything
water king Alexander the sword chose you
while we help you because you're the
strongest people I know you're my
Knights and this is the round table
quick bonus different flaps oh my god
you're such a nerd this is this
it's like in every story we have a right
Luke Skywalker Harry Potter something
amazing happens they find out I
descended from magical families mom
don't freak out okay
this is the best
all hail the once and future king please
don't
it's embarrassing
did you drive Mario Kart
there's one thing I know about the world
it's not the little things that matter
it's the tiny things do you want a tiny
piece of cheese yes yes she's is my life
[Music]
my name is Bella and this is how I met
Lucas see those thing I really like you
maybe that's a sign her home supposed to
be with me don't choose shoes oh uh
don't you shoot that one was his
favorite over the years we did
everything together
girl we chased a squirrel
[Music]
we went to work we even played a game
called doctor doctor doctor game
everything all right yeah yeah life with
Lucas was the best but when he wasn't
around I missed him so much that
squirrel again squirrel squirrel
[Music]
it looks like she needs help
where the James I was very far from home
but I knew Lucas was waiting for me and
I had to go and find him
[Music]
even better than a tiny piece of cheese
we all face things that are hard the
only thing that gets us through it are
the special people in our lives and I
was never going to stop searching until
I found mine
[Music]
that dog saved his life
[Music]
our
[Music]
you know how flemeth like to say
everybody knows everything
[Music]
it would be fine if the truth was it
nobody does anything Alan laughing I'm
gonna that feels like we've all been
here forever
where's this just a little scratch
please don't kill that man what I will
give you ten million dollars Strout my
husband in the ocean for the sharks is
right and wrong heaven in hell weird
stuff going on right now
this old irons a part of it but nobody
knows it
okay Johnny wanted juice you don't
it's funny huh where in the world are we
[Music]
I'm very honored to be named keyhole of
Citizen of the Year I'm just a guy who
keeps strip of civilization a woman when
you drive to see the day after day is
easy to think about the road not taken
I was lucky I picked a good road early
and the state I'm mister cocksman what
can I do for you it's about your son
[Music]
died of a heroin overdose
we had no around Kyle wasn't a druggie
sorry but I'll compare and say that
you're gonna have to say a few words
Kyle's dip
tell me what happened you gotta mix it
up what's up drug dealer why can't you
like certain people with this with all
these nicknames speedo viking Eskimo
it's a gangster thing did you have a
nickname wingman wait a man gonna kill
him
no guys one guy could disappear too who
wants me dead
three of Vikings drug dealers who
disappeared what makes you think you
know better crime novel
what are you doing
job
this doesn't happen in kyo it just did
Nell's cocksman citizen to the year good
for him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
was fall with
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome baby Dumbo
well family here no matter how small
[Music]
[Music]
yes something very rare
you have wonder
[Music]
you have mystique
you have magic
[Music]
come with me
together we can soar on the elephant's
wings
what's happening were they taking her
take Dumbo back inside but she's his mom
do something she needs us look at me
we're gonna bring your mama huh
he doesn't look like magic to me
[Music]
your children need you to believe
you can do a Dumbo show
[Applause]
quite a moment
fly baby
[Music]
once everything was awesome
now everything is okay Lucy I brought
you coffee coffee the bitter liquid that
provides the only semblance of pleasure
left in these dark time oh my gosh Ness
did I interrupt you brooding just now
times have changed
you need to change with them we have to
be tough and battle-ready
Oh
[Music]
sorry the door is slowly
Oh Jane its Jane so cold
see that wasn't so bad nothing got in
[Applause]
we're going I don't get it we'll help me
rescue my friends you don't want to go
anywhere near that sistar system it's
ruled by an alien coin only the toughest
you're gonna get out of there alive
I'm a queen whatever I would not be I'm
getting super evil vibes here I could
change my form to something else if this
makes you uncomfortable
hey guys he'll go back don't worst was
much more palatable double dots on your
feet
who are you I'm your worst nightmare Oh
me when I'm late to school and I forgot
my homework and my pants are made of
pudding no I don't it's time to open the
park Wonderland is now open
I like it when the ideas come from you
now the facts that I'm talking about
operation looky-loo is it go
honey if you see my cellphone where did
your model go I don't play that anymore
hey get back here
seriously
[Music]
welcome to the park have a nice day how
is this possible hello my name is Steve
I know who you are you know who we are
my mom and I invented this place and
somehow you came to life
we're alive what happened here the
darkness happened it brought an army of
chimpanzees but so naughty it's time to
bring the park back to light who's with
me
oh no he's allergic to voluntary
[Music]
such a woman those come-hither tusks
[Music]
well that didn't work out at least we
got dinner
EPG so scrolls are the bad guys
and you're a Cree a race of noble boys
heroes
noble warrior heroes
[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory we made you
one of us so you could live longer
stronger superior
you were reborn
I keep having these
memories something in my past is the key
to all of this
you're not a flatus think we'll see
that's a yes or no question yes
[Music]
would you like to know
but you really are
[Music]
I think I said a life here
what aren't you telling me
we've come a long way
but you know as strong as you think
[Music]
the small cysts the beginning I'm not
gonna fight your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
[Music]
I've stood a cute is love thing aren't
you
yeah what's your name
[Music]
there are moments in our lives that seem
to define us chooser there are you a
virgin I dare you to make out with her
I'm done playing this game but isn't it
really about what lies beyond those
moments what are you doing I think you
owe me a dad so what's his story
be careful hardness complicated what are
you dreaming about
[Music]
[Music]
my life before him was so simple and now
there's just after identity scan
initiated
[Music]
hello agent sterling
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it worked
subject appears disoriented Walter what
did you do everywhere nobody notices
them it's the most perfect form of I
could taste unburden me right now
stop girl seriously Lance look at me
look at you I can't not look at you
Walter I can see my butt and your face
at the same time
[Music]
so happy at jury here after my parents
died and I didn't really think I was
gonna be able to come back to Tijuana
but you always made me feel like family
you are my family
[Music]
[Music]
America's Angela I just wanna find my
friend I need you to do a favor for me
first
you mess around I'll kill you both
depart the car real close to the curb
you see you have to believe me they made
me do it the building that you blew up
the DEA safe house you know how long you
go away for unless you help us you know
Esparza
see the face
forget your friends who's coming to save
you whether or not you survive
entirely up to you
you gotta learn how to use one of these
illallah bullet balleseros everything
ever since you showed up the police in
one step ahead
you better do what you need to do Toledo
has a mole in his operation I'm not
giving up on my family
Lila in the end
the bullet that was everything
[Music]
little box on the hillside little boxes
made of kiki tacky little boxes only the
sign and they all look just the same you
want to control your life but life isn't
a science experiment you can't contain
your world forever try doing one thing
that scares you over break okay yeah
this serves as an entry voucher for
mimics escape rooms immersive room yet
and win a million dollars
so uh when does the game start I think
this is the escape room we should look
for clues what are we looking for here
anything that looks like a puzzle or
code it looks like an oven dial that's
creepy as hell for 50 money
talk about a person what's wrong with
you that was real
Wow
dumb question are we outside soon we get
this figured on soon we get the hell out
of here
little box are watching us to know
everyone relations everything about us
this is my hospital bed me too
they made these rooms for us I never
seen things that weren't there before
that's why they chose us and they all
look
I'll wear it has never been in more
danger
[Music]
human worried is what drove us
underground all those years ago to
escape from your rapacious appetite
[Music]
I warn you boy
[Music]
you are not prepared for the truth
behind what you seek
[Music]
no you will be
two best fair
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's just a movie
you see Natalie's lots not a fairytale
girls like us don't get that oh why look
in the mirror doll when though Julia
Roberts
every day day swipe my father about me
Nataly saying that romantic comedies are
about all those maybes allows it to
terrible pop songs I think people would
have an easier time seeing you if you
were a little more open you're in the
emergency room this isn't an emergency
room this is at Williamson I'm on my way
downtown it looks like somebody's what a
beauty filter across New York City and I
win one what's your emergency
someone's broken into my apartment and
they've taken everything and replace it
all with much nicer stuff so your
emergency is that your apartment is too
big and you have every shoe you could
ever want yeah exactly that's what I
yeah you gonna go crazy I hit my head
really hard and I woke up in this
alternate universe and now I have a gay
sidekick who's sitting gay rights back
like 100 years of love working the legs
and guys look at me in the eyes you're
caught beguiling aren't you are you
feeling what I'm feeling
No
I think I'm trapped in a romantic comedy
[Applause]
I'm Pei boots what's they up there I
have to get a man to fall in love with
me I'm Josh he's such a beautiful me
[Music]
good morning beautiful last night was
amazing I think we actually did anything
it just cut to the next morning what
just get that here okay last night was
amazing Natalie I love you've run from
foster homes in six counties I can't
take care of myself when you're 18 give
these people a chance because that's
what they're giving you this is Billy
Batson make sure you make him feel at
home they seem nice but don't buy it it
gets real gameofthrones around here dude
just mess around you look at me and
you're like why so dark you're disabled
- Oscar kid you've got it all if you
could have one superpower what would you
think everybody chooses flight you know
why so they can fly away from this
conversation no cuz heroes fly
well you need your fake family to stand
up for you hey man sorry about that
Billy Batson I choose you
escape
hello say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir sure Sam wait for you okay
Shazam
Billy you're the only person I know that
knows anything about this Cape Crusader
stuff tonight yeah it's crazy right what
are your superpowers superpowers dude I
don't even know how to pee in this thing
can you fly okay
why are you talking
you know I'm gonna buff out your
co-stars your phone charge help these
like a bad guy right
you have full immunity
wolfram you're dead sorry about your
window
you're welcome for not getting robbed oh
hey stop I'm a superhero you think you
can fix me Jean you are not broken
beautiful red the pine there's a fragile
thing takes only the slightest tap to
tip it in the wrong direction
Charles what did you do I had to keep a
stable I protected her from the truth
there's another word for that I came
looking for answers you feel like you
don't belong here
you don't they can't begin to comprehend
what you are she's changing it's what we
didn't come here looking for answers you
came here looking for permission
she's a pain
miss water coming out of us Jean Laskin
fault is she still a Fed this is your
fault Charles the world is on the brink
I'm sorry I didn't stop it sooner you're
always sorry Charles
and as always a speaks and nobody cares
there's still hope
don't do this
[Music]
the right to see me I've seen Abel
[Music]
I'm looking at it now
[Applause]
[Music]
thousands of angel hair
and ice-cream
means everywhere
I put the glass up way
but now
hey ray
so
things I would've done but
[Music]
[Music]
this blows
I really don't know
[Music]
I don't belong here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey somebody get him before he pokes an
eye out
[Music]
rise and shine breakfast is ready in ten
minutes and don't make me come back up
there this is our town it's a close-knit
community the kind of place where
everyone knows everyone understood hey
how are you girls and we're always there
for each other nice sermon pastor well
you guys have on for the rest today
well dawn has a basketball game yeah
I've seen this guy goop it up around
here this kid is so rich text your mom
tomorrow until I win and where to pick
you up and don't do anything stupid
[Applause]
Timmy he's been underwater for more than
15 minutes it's going to be a recovery
I'm gonna rescue you've done everything
medically possible there's nothing more
would you do please God send your spirit
there's a must
[Music]
a fourteen-year-old st. Charles boy who
spent 15 minutes trapped underwater is
continuing to fight for his life
I don't believe John will survive the
night you don't know my son he is a
fighter so I need you to be the best for
John and you just let God do the rest
you are my pride and joy I can't wait to
see you those baskets in run up and down
again the Smith family asked for one
thing please pray for John in the water
that day I was ready to give up but then
I hear this voice is telling me go back
either I'm nuts or God's talking to you
but I don't believe in God I believe but
maybe that only goes so far something
like this now to your pastor I'm
supposed to walk alongside you for as
long as it takes
did you see the Facebook page Ellen
viral Tommy
I hope is going to be okay
we're not gonna get through this alone
whatever you have for me
[Music]
you place your passion father do you
know anything about La Llorona
the reaping woman
it was a folk down
- so stay in the car okay
and please don't wake up your sister I
try to snubber
who did you try to stop by your owner
[Music]
recursively ah
[Music]
[Music]
does it bother you that I'm not
completely human you were the most human
person I have ever met
[Music]
didn't I tell you to be home before dark
I just lost track of time
bolita you have to be responsible
where's someone very special hey kid
not just a teenage girl hey what's your
problem you can't remember what do you
mean doc found you in the scrap yard so
you must be from up there and I'm just
an insignificant girl that's what they
want you to think
I'm not your daughter I don't know what
I am
I don't yet the most advanced weapon
ever
but that's just a shell it's not bad or
good that part's up to you
I do not stand by
the presence of evil
she's threatening the natural order of
things
tonight is not a game
it is a heart
I need you to destroy the girl called
Aleta
you made the biggest mistake of your
life
and what's that
under estimating Who I am
[Applause]
[Music]
so many trees it's beautiful right
that's definitely not Boston
here we go okay so what do you think wow
this whole place is ours I even got into
throwing a whole forest as a new
backyard
[Music]
it was a missed kids we used to dare
each other go into the woods at night
[Music]
they knew the power of that place they
feared it those woods belong to
something else
[Music]
the round is bad it may be just some
crazy folktale there is something up in
those woods something it brings things
back
sometimes dead is better welcome to
rhyming city a celebration of the
harmony between humans and pokémon Tim
your dad was a legend in this precinct
if you were anything like your tanner
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah
yeah they didn't really worked out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are and not to
use this
geez here we go I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I will electrocute you did you just
talk whoa did you just understand me oh
my god you can understand me I've been
so lonely they try to talk to me all the
time all they hear is pika pika you can
hear him right you're adorable
they can't understand me kiss you no one
else I don't need a Pokemon period and
what about a world-class detective
because if you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
it brought us together and that magic is
called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine
yeah so tell us what we want to know
pipe yes okay I can shoving pushing my
problem is that I push people away and
then hate them for leaving he's saying
you can shove it what I can shove it
okay that's it no we're switching roles
I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]
hello
is anyone there
I'm trying to reach
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
senators we believe that these Titans
are just the tip of the iceberg which of
these Titans are here to protect us and
[Music]
which of these Titans are here to
threaten us
so you'd want to make Godzilla our pet
no we would be his you're sure he's
gonna be okay
they're everywhere battling for
dominance
arrival alpha to Godzilla you gotta be
kidding
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you are a gift
I know it's been difficult for you baby
things feel different from other kids
you are different
[Music]
after your dad and I got married we
prayed for a baby for so long
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we believe that you came here for a
reason
he was in the barn did he find it no it
was like he was drawn
he may look like us
these Mallika's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there are moments in a rockstars life
that define who he is where there was
darkness there is no you and it's going
to be a wild ride
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna ask you a series of questions
I want you to respond truthfully have
you ever heard someone yes have you ever
experienced anything you'd consider
ignore me
[Music]
yes
last question do you know a mutants are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous and adult ones they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Applause]
all of you are dangerous
that's why you're here
[Music]
what is this place hospital
[Applause]
[Music]
you're being through hot get some rest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]